of Jason we please and that the portrait
of the optimization results lately okay
yeah so today I'm going to talk today
and tomorrow I'm going to talk about
mostly about optimization and over
privatization in the context of neural
networks
okay so roughly speaking today we're
probably going to get to 1 and 2 today
the slides for 3 and 4 don't completely
exist yet so we probably won't get there
so the first thing I'll talk about is
what is over parameterize ation we use
this term a lot like what is an over
Prime tries Network how you can modify
architectures to make them more amenable
to optimization to in particular to
gradient based optimization then I'll
talk about these more geometric results
on over parameterization I'll start off
by reviewing what kind of non convex
problems are easy that can be solved
just purely because they have certain
geometric properties and then I'll move
on to search non algorithmic results
that are kind of suggestive in nature
that's a that kind of suggests that
although deep learning is non convex the
loss function is non convex but they
have no local minima and dark-eyed
results with no direct algorithmic
implications but they are suggestive in
point out that over parameterization is
doing something interesting the plan for
tomorrow is talk about algorithmic
results in particular this line of work
using gradient dynamics near the
initialization and then perhaps if we
have time talk about a washer sign flow
viewpoint of gradient descent so two
different viewpoints one is kind of
local and when is global but that's for
tomorrow
ok so today the goal for these two days
is the look at optimization and over
parameterization it's essentially a
survey of results and then some of it
with my own perspectives and
of how to interpret these results
because the literature is vast I haven't
read every paper but I've kind of
grouped the papers and in my head in a
way and then I'm going to explain like
this grouping essentially okay so what
is over parameterize ation what what it
what does this term even mean okay so
before we go on let's look at what's
hard about deep learning why do we need
to look at over parameterize neural
networks the first thing that's
difficult is roughly you can split into
two halves one is optimization so this
is purely the problem of trying to
minimize a non-convex loss for example
the logistic regression loss where your
predictor is a network or the square
loss when the predictors network these
are non convex in the parameters of the
network and in fact due to symmetries
they have many many critical points they
probably have many many local minima and
so forth and of course the second half
is statistical is not only do we care
about minimizing the loss but we care
about doing well on unseen data I won't
really focus much on this except to talk
about how it's related to over
privatization so of course these are
intertwined then they're not easily
decoupled for example it's not too hard
to get the optimization error to zero
but then you might be terribly
overfitting and so forth it's easy to
talk about there exist networks that
have good test error but you know you
can't find them with local search so the
question is of the main challenge is how
to find a network efficiently using
local search that also generalize as
well I won't get to this today but
tomorrow I'll talk about how this recent
line of work using neural tangent
Cardinals can get the optimization Eric
very low and kind of get something
reasonable for the statistical error
perhaps not super good but at least it's
not you're getting some generalization
okay so they're intertwined I'm going to
try didn't break today I'm only going to
talk about optimization essentially okay
so of course a non convex optimization
is is it should be hard but practically
speaking if I ran stochastic gradient on
all the common networks resna 50
whatever vgg you would find that the
training loss is very small the training
error is like zero the training loss
itself is near zero
like point o1 and this is somewhat
surprising right I'm initializing at
random my algorithm is completely naive
it only sees gradients or sub gradients
and it's just following these negative
gradients and somehow it never gets
stuck this is somewhat amazing that if
you contrast this to what you would
theoretically expect on the theoretical
side everything is hard for example you
can have you could try to fit a loss
function with a single neuron and a
sigmoid activation and when the when the
data is not realizable the loss function
has a lot of critical points or
exponentially many local minima that was
shown a long time ago in this paper here
and there's many many other hardness
results I suggest that you should not be
able to do to learn these for example
it's known that even if your data set is
separable by logarithmically many or
sorry super logarithmically many read
lose so you have a teacher network that
consists of read lose kayra lose and
they separate with positive margin you
should not be able to learn in
polynomial in the number of relics you
have that's what these results kind of
suggest ok so the main question of this
tutorial is to understand why stochastic
gradient is successful why on these
terribly non convex problems it can
still minimize a training loss notice
the second one is the hardness is about
learning so it doesn't preclude getting
the training loss to zero necess
but the first one does say that even
when my last one she has one year on the
training loss is bad already okay let me
define my setting so I'm going to this
is my last function I may or may not
have a regularizer the loss will be
either square loss or logistic loss and
potentially like a hinge loss or a
smooth hinge loss but it's a univariate
function it's convex in the argument Y
hat the network is denoted F theta at X
so it's what the neural net predicts X
I'm only going to look as scaler outputs
in theta what they know all the
parameters in network so all the weights
and we're only going to look at one
algorithm gradient descent or SGD is you
simply move theta in the direction of
the negative loss okay so some more
notation is so the set of all parameters
out the know theta the weight of
individual layers I'm going to denote w
sub L and our sometimes treat the output
layer in a special manner I'll call it a
so a is a vector because I have scalar
output and W sub L are matrices of size
M by M I'll use square for convenience M
is the number of filters number neurons
per layer the input is going to be in D
dimensions the width is always m and the
depth is L okay so the total number of
parameters so the if you take all the WS
and A's and concatenate them I'll call
that P and there's going to be an
samples so the goal of optimization is
to minimize the following training loss
rate I want this to be 0 if it's square
loss if it's logistic loss I want to be
very very close to 0
okay so now I'm going to talk about what
is over parameterization and why do we
need it okay so like I already told you
even in the single neuron case when the
data is not realizable or it's not
realizable plus noise there's
exponentially many local minimum so
obviously gradient descent is going to
get stuck if you commit to using that
loss rate of course the goal of machine
learning is not to do optimization
optimization is simply you know a way to
try and learn a good classifier so we
don't commit to using that loss function
if I'm doing the only optimization I'm
dead like if your goal is to minimize
the loss that's hard but we're all we're
doing learning so we can change the loss
function what is the simplest way to
change a loss function it's to alter the
model to alter the architecture right so
even if my model came from a realizable
single neuron with plus some weird noise
to make it hard
I can always decide okay I'm going to
use fit a different model and then with
this different model I may be able to
get their training loss to zero more
easily using stochastic gradient okay
just for example it might have the
property there's no bad local
minimizer's or perhaps as the property
that there's a solution near random
initialization meaning you randomly
initialize and you're in the basin of
attraction of a minimizer okay so
basically you're going to change the
model to make the landscape the loss the
landscape look better this is some
illustration it's not very good because
I don't think this is I'm not saying
this is what the losses look like but
the point is here it'll succeed and on
the left they'll fail terribly okay so
what is the simplest way to to change
the architecture or change the model I
fit one very simple way is to just over
prom trace for example if I for some
reason believe that the Nate data is
pitiable by this small network with 50
neurons
I can decide to use a model with a
hundred neurons right and then it's
empirically observed that it's easier
somehow it's easier for SGD the training
loss is nicer when you use a hundred
neurons rather than 50 right with 50
neurons you frequently get stuck in
crappy local minimizer's or the gradient
vanishes whatever and with a hundred you
do well so here's an experiment showing
this what I did is I generated data from
this two layer model in 50 dimensions
and there's 50 neurons the weight matrix
is just identity so the simplest way
matrix in the world and then my labels
why come from this true teacher network
so it's completely realizable and then
my model is also this teacher network
I run SGD five times and then I plot the
lost value so you can see that getting
two different unique values of the loss
and neither of them are zero the global
minimum is zero I mean I know that there
exists a model with 50 neurons I get 0
error namely W star which was the
identity matrix
but as G Deane can never find it I mean
you can run instead of 5 times you run
it 50 times this still doesn't find it
and in 50 dimensions you'll never find
this if you just use SGD okay so clearly
the lost landscape is not good right and
this is kind of not surprising you know
your 50 dimensions in non-convex
optimization of course you would expect
that you very rarely find the global
minimizer and in fact you should get
very different quality local minimizer's
depending on your initialization your
learning rate schedule so forth
on the right hand side my data
generating distribution is the same
thing my data still comes from this
teacher small teacher network with 50
neurons but I decide to use a different
model I don't know why but I decided
that I want to use a model with a
hundred neurons now of course this seems
statistically silly I know the model the
true model had only 50 neurons why am I
wasting all this parameters potentially
losing statistical efficiency increasing
my computation time I mean there's a lot
of drawbacks here for sure well
magically I call SGD five times with
different initializations a different
node data
I mean it's stochastic data the data is
coming in stochastically this is one
pass SGD and the objective the training
lost value or actually this is
populations one pass SG so the
population loss is now going to zero
okay and it doesn't matter where I
initialize I you know it's you can see
that it's getting a global min or very
very close to global min something I
point to one in the training loss okay
so this is kind of surprising right I
knew my model was well specified and I
decide to fit the big architecture to
make it misspecified and then but now
the optimization algorithm is working
from the perspective of optimization
I've somehow magically made the training
landscape very good or even the
population loss very good more amenable
to SGD any questions before I continue
the weights it converges to how
different are they different runs and
how to be very different they're not the
true weights they're very different but
they have population loss zero near zero
yeah I mean you there's some patterns
like you can see like sometimes you
capture a little bit of identity but
there I didn't see any you know nothing
stood out I guess yeah something like
around 55 it didn't work and then 70 is
started working and then I just made it
a hundred so there's a phase transition
Oh HUD and his student have a paper that
empirically looked at this a little bit
and they found when you're a true model
was twenty neurons and use 21 is still
gets stuck and if you use 22 it didn't
get stuck so I mean no one knows and
this is an interesting theoretical
question like you would conjecture maybe
if you had K neurons here something like
K log K it would work I think it's true
no one can prove it
that would be one open problem yeah the
axis are Gaussian yeah yeah the axes are
standard normal and iid okay yeah so
there's some phase transition but I have
no idea where it is okay so sort of this
summarizes this conventional wisdom on
what over parameterization is doing yeah
you have a fire at the end so if they
who was a mission of 2000 you might be
learning as a fire but he just comes
from a single Gauss then what is the
second layer it's right crashing
crashing yeah and how do you generate
the
wait for a second also plus minus 1that
random yeah
[Applause]
okay so kind of this is the the rule of
thumb is if your SGD is not finding low
training error then you better you
should make your model bigger and then
somehow by making a throwing in a bigger
model SGD is more likely to get low
training and kind of we see this happen
all the time in practice is that the
models are fairly big when we get bigger
data sets also we get we make we use
bigger models
so of course one theoretical problem to
ask is how much over parameterize do you
need to optimize and what does it mean
for the the statistical the test error
right just purely computationally adding
throwing in more parameters increases
computation or memory cost I mean you
know optimizing one milk 1 billion
parameters is not easy and naively you
may think that too many parameters may
lead to overfitting for example when I
increase this I doubled the number of
parameters roughly and of course you
would think to learn this model with
twice as many parameters may need price
as many samples so clearly if you can
minimize overall models with 50 neurons
and you had another Oracle here this one
might be statistically more efficient
what what do you mean by sparsity it's a
full rank matrix at that sorry it's it's
a hundred by 50 but it's on train yes
are they most of is this power solution
no they're tense there's no structure
popping out
okay yeah so you may think that also
you're making optimization easier but
perhaps your heart making statistics
harder this is also a possibility so
then you want to kind of find a sweet
spot or this phase transition like you
mentioned is that what point can i
efficiently optimize what is the minimal
amount of parameters I need to
efficiently optimize okay so obviously
if your labels were arbitrary you need
the number of parameters the big bigger
than the sample size this is just simple
dimension counting informally is that if
I have n label if I have n equations
then I need as many parameters to move
around to fit all the equations I say I
need P bigger than n so this is like
worst case a more interesting question
is if the data the labels are structured
the axes and wise were structured can
the amount of over parameterization
adapt to this latent structure in the
labels then obviously you wouldn't need
this worse case anymore
okay so kind of a taxonomy of the
results I'm over parameterization the
first category of results are mostly
geometry or topology based they're kind
of non algorithmic they say things like
all local minima or global or all strict
local minima or global or some you know
variation of this this is the first
category of results the second category
of results is are based on these local
dynamics they've been referred to as a
lazy regime or the kernel regime and
they utilize local linear behavior of
the network predictions what's
surprising here is using a purely local
analysis you can argue you get a global
often the third category of results is
these more global dynamics or active
training or I don't know what the right
term is they're kind of characterized by
the parameters moving a lot from the
initialization the parameters are kind
of forgetting where they start okay so
for today I think I will probably cover
the first one and maybe a little bit the
second one all right oh yeah and before
I go on I want to talk about one more
architecture design concept basically
skip connections so over primate
relation is increasing the width and
this is very useful if you have a
shallow Network and you want to prevent
gradient vanishing you did make the
width bigger
similarly if you have very deep networks
even if when they're over Prime tries
the gradients are may vanish just
because you have small numbers being
multiplied all times if you're out depth
one simple idea is just to use skip
connections or as Nets is to just add
these links over here and that way the
gradients you can when you take a
gradient of a very early layer they can
they don't disappear so this is also
another type of architecture design that
I'll talk about briefly later too okay
and it's worth mentioning roughly these
have the same expressivity power as a
regular network right so resna is not
really increasing the expressivity or
anything it's purely to make
optimization easier in a sense I don't
know what it does the statistical error
but it definitely isn't making it more
expressive anyway right you can
basically express the same class of
functions here in here basically at the
width so we're talking about you can
express all functions informally but
this is a just a way to reap Ramat rice
so that stochastic gradient is less
likely to get stuck okay so let's move
on to these geometric results on over
parameterization I'm going to start off
by reviewing generic non convex
optimization and then I'll go on to
specific results in deep learning
okay so sort of these geometry results
you they roughly are they roughly have
two steps in the first step you say
something about gradient based or local
search algorithms for example we know
generically the gradient stochastic
gradient or gradient descent will always
find the first order stationary point
somewhere where the gradient is zero or
more or with a little bit more work you
can show they find the second order
stationary point so then we know that no
matter what these algorithms get certain
type of critical points and the second
step is to show that these critical
points have good properties maybe
they're global minimizer's are close to
global minimizer's so you can separate
things into two steps okay so what is
the first time so even when the function
is non complex people have identifying
these numerous things that look like
convexity they go by various names
quasi-convex
one-point convex the regularity
condition blah blah blah
they all look like they all basically
say the same thing they say the gradient
when the gradient vanishes something
good happens so for example this
condition which is very similar to quasi
convexity it says if you the gradient
inner product with theta minus theta
star which is the direction I want to go
to because I want to move towards theta
start is lower bounded by some distance
optimality this D of theta theta star
for example I just need something
positive here basically unless I'm
optimal when it's optimal it can be zero
when I'm not an optimal I need something
strictly positive for example if it's
bigger than L of theta minus L of theta
star this is sort of like quasi
convexity and you can see it has a
property that unless I'm optimal then
this is strictly positive and if I take
a gradient descent step i thus move
towards theta start
here's a more fancy version goes by
various names but basically it's just a
mix of two terms it's saying that this
is the more important term it's saying
that I'm lower bounded I'm like strongly
convex in this one direction it's saying
that there's strong convexity in the
direction of theta to theta star so
perhaps I'm not globally strongly convex
or even in the ball I'm strongly convex
it along one direction and this is the
one direction that matters because it's
what gradient descent is looking at and
if this holds you can also prove a
convergence rate for a gradient descent
to theta star again this side is only
zero when you're at the optimum here
okay so quasi convexity is so this is
slightly like epsilon away from
convexity where you can still say that
gradient descent is finding a global
minimizer okay so so I'll call all of
these quasi-convex here one-point
convexity people have used this in in
some simplified neural net settings they
essentially all look like this where
this is something quantitative and it's
different for every paper okay the
simplest one is where you have one
neuron okay so it's realizable why is
rallo of WX sigmoid of WX it really
doesn't matter I think it just needs to
be convex or monotone either convex or
monotone will work for example in in
this word interflow paper it was a
square function for quadratic function
basically phase retrieval in these
functions it was like sigmoid or some
monotone function and then in these ones
this was like a Ray Lu cure and all of
these is quasi it has this kind of
geometric property that the gradient
points in the right direction
similarly for when you have a single
convolutional filter with non
overlapping patches so this is a shift
operation they don't overlap then it
also has this property is shown by Bruce
Kison glow Burson first
you also have this one point convexity
in a neighborhood around the identity
this in these papers by Lee and Rin
basically they wrote it as a ResNet but
what it boils down to is if W star is
the identity then there is a radius of
constant spectral norm roughly less than
0.07 such that it has one point
convexity so if you started in if you if
your W star was close to identity and
you start within a constant spectral
norm then gradient descent converges to
W star and also shown for linear
dynamical systems in this paper by heart
by rect they showed that a form of this
one point complexity firstly table blue
is the hidden layer weight goes to some
and they are good yes the second layer
had to be all positive it's just
something it's just something yeah
that's right and us so a small spectral
norm radius around W star but only for W
star in your identity so
okay so this is sort of kind of the
easiest way to prove something is you
only use a gradient using only
first-order conditions although it's non
convex you can say something and you can
see I mean these it's pretty limited the
list here very simple neural nets
essentially one year on models okay
and over prom tribes networks is kind of
inconvenient to be talking about theta
star right because if it's over
parameters theta stars not identifiable
so the theta star you go to may depend
on where you start your learning rate so
forth so it's but so what's frequently
used is this poly a gradient domination
condition sorry there's a type of this
should be squared in this gradient
domination condition I don't need a no a
theta star is I only need to know what L
of theta star is throughout today L of
theta star will always be zero I'm
assuming I can fit the data so it just
says that the gradient doesn't vanish as
long as I'm my loss is not at the global
optimum my gradient is something
positive and gradient descent always
makes progress proportional to the
square of the gradient so then you
always make progress if you have this
gradient domination condition so it's
basically immediate to prove that if
this were true then gradient descent
gets a global optimum at a linear
convergence rate okay so when does this
hold this condition is useful for over
parametrized models basically this
condition holds for locally near a small
radius in Frobenius norm for over
parametrize models and it holds globally
for it also owes globally for over
parametrize models assuming you
initialize in the using xavier using a
like laocoon initialization essentially
I'll talk about this later today or
tomorrow and interestingly in res Nets
is satisfies the polyak condition this
polyak gradient condition in some large
region around initial
zatia and this is something you get from
using linear rez notes instead of linear
network sorry it doesn't I'm saying that
if you wanted to use this one in May
because if you're over prom Christ theta
star is like the global menu go to now
but which one are you going to you don't
know right yeah
okay so pop so this is also again a
first-order condition that's useful in
the over parametrize case to get global
convergence to a global min for gradient
descent okay so of course what these two
have in common is you want to avoid
spurious gradient vanishing where you
the the one thing that kills gradient
descent is the gradient is zero or near
zero but you're not yet at the global
minima that's what both of these are
ensured this is saying the norm squared
of the gradients lower bounded this one
saying the gradient in a particular
direction is lower bounded they kind of
morally they're the same thing the
gradient doesn't vanish unless I'm at a
global optimum or somehow close to it
okay so what if the gradient is zero
then are we dead okay so let's look at
Taylor's theorem so just Taylor's apply
Taylor's theorem to the loss and let's
say the gradient term the first order
term is zero or it's nearly zero it's so
small it's not going to help you okay so
what to do here we're still okay if
theta minus theta zero is aligned with a
negative eigen vector of the hessian
right a theta zero so when the first
order time is zero it goes away if I can
make this negative then I'm safe I can
still decrease the loss right okay so
what is an obvious algorithm that can
use this to avoid gradient vanishing and
Hessian vanishing so here is an
algorithm by Royer and right it's
probably older than that I think it's
very simple you just run gradient
descent until your gradient is like zero
then you compute the negative
eigenvector if the negative eigenvalue
is not zero or sorry is away from zero
you move in the direction you'd let DK
be a negative eigenvector and you move
in that direction if and then you loop
again when the gradient you keep running
gradient descent and hold the gradient
zero and then you try to escape okay so
this is pretty obvious that this
algorithm is going to succeed
in finding a place where the gradient is
roughly zero and the Hessian is positive
semi-definite why is this let's say the
gradient is not zero then the gradient
descent step is moving right this step
the first phase of the algorithm is
making progress if the Hessian is not
PSD then there is a negative eigenvector
and it's going to move in that direction
here okay so when this algorithm does
terminate according to these tolerances
whatever it is here and here then
they'll find a point where this is less
than epsilon and this is bigger than
minus Epsilon okay so if theta satisfies
the above two conditions we'll call it a
second-order stationary point so
reasonable algorithms that use
second-order information can find
second-order stationary point this
algorithm here has some running times
that's polynomial and everything
okay so here's just a picture these
points are the ones we're getting out of
using the negative curvature if I'm
exactly here then the item with the
gradient is 0 but the eigenvector
computation is going to see this
direction and move it off this kind of
point this kind of point we don't worry
about out then we're going to get a
local min like here okay so some very
informally seeps speaking a second-order
stationary point is sort of like a local
min okay so of course you know there's I
showed you the algorithm for escaping
second-order when they're second-order
and negative curvature there's an
obvious way to generalize this algorithm
is you run gradient descent and hold the
gradient 0 then you take a step in the
negative eigenvalue if that's zero then
you try to use a third order tensor find
negative curvature there and you keep
going higher and higher I mean this
algorithm will work unfortunately
computing these negative curvature
directions becomes hard a fourth order
so third order saddle points can be
escaped you by essentially an algorithm
that tries to find third order negative
curvature and but as soon as you go to
fourth order saddle points it's hard
it's it's you can reduce code positivity
testing to fourth order saddle points
this is kind of bad news generically
speaking neural Nets of depth L will
have saddles of order L for example even
a linear network has a saddle of order L
just because X to the 8th power is a
saddle of order L
so in summary and ok let me just make a
remark that second order stationary
points with equality constraints is the
same algorithm but as soon as you have
constrained optimization to NP hard you
can yeah
promise that you will find this point a
polynomial number of iterations right so
so the harness is hot is fine but in
saying you all will always make progress
but will you reach this local minimum
polynomial time yes oh you will yes yes
you make sufficient descent yeah the
hardness is if you could compute
arbitrary order tensor eigen values then
an algorithm that looks like this will
make sufficient progress every step the
hardness is finding these negative
curvatures at fourth and higher order
you don't need any assumption on the
tensor it's not really computing a
tensor eigenvalue in this paper I think
it was doing some random projection
thing and then it showed that with like
some small number of projections they
can find it I think that was roughly
though to explicitly compute negative
curvature directions no it's not like
randomly perturb parameters right that's
next slide your one slide ahead of me
yeah okay yes so yeah so okay so on the
the previous prototype typical algorithm
use second order information
the obvious question now is you know
frequently Hessian vector products are
expensive in pipe arch tensor flow so
forth if we have no access to the
Hessian can we also avoid saddle points
so naively you might think this is
difficult because you know if the
gradient is zero gradient this I should
be stuck right
it doesn't really see the Hasina at all
okay but this is where randomness comes
in let's look at a small toy calculation
imagine that theta zero is zero and zero
is a critical point the gradient is
exactly zero and we run GD from a small
infinitely small perturbation of zero
the iterates will roughly look like this
they look like identity - a step size of
the Hessian razor teeth power and notice
this is seeing second order information
the gradient term is gone because the
gradient is zero so then I when you
apply identity - step size times Hessian
what this is doing is power narration on
the Hessian so at critical points
gradient descent in fact does see second
order information because the gradient
term is cotton and away from critical
points it sees no second in order
information because it's dominated by
the gradient term okay so how can you
use this here's a picture that's
illustrating the same thing zero was my
saddle point if I start anywhere near
zero I'm doing power iteration and
eventually I will escape I'll go in and
I escape like this so basically as long
as you have some randomness you escape
the saddle points this is just saying
the same thing it's a set of measure
zero that you can do get attracted to
these saddle points okay so what is the
theorem the formal theorem you can prove
is that a function is smooth and
coercive coercive just means that the
gradient blows up as I go to infinity I
don't want to function like e to the
minus X you know because there's no
critical points then gradient descent
with additional noise or some source of
randomness either stochastic or I inject
the artificially doesn't really matter
only affects the rates I get a a
second-order stationary point or Absalon
second-order seizure the gradient will
be epsilon and the Hessian will be
bigger than - absolutely
so what this means is that gradient
descent with randomness will find a
second-order stationary point in
polynomial time any questions here
yeah you don't need sorry you do need if
you want polynomial time you need a
quantitative bound on the Lipschitz of
the Hessian if you only want it
asymptotically you don't need it but you
need c2 regardless I don't think you can
escape saddle points with just c1 the
difficulty of saddle points with just c1
is essentially the same as finding a
second-order station point with
constrained optimization because with
constraints you create essentially this
it's a boundary behavior will kill you
okay so just summary is gradient based
algorithms find second-order stationary
points okay so what this means is that
we can now look at a larger class of
problems right before I was only using
that the gradient is non vanishing
implies global optimality now I can say
the gradient is non vanishing or the
Hessian is non negative so this is I can
look at a larger class of problems than
before this has been done so these for a
large list of problems now pretty large
list second-order stationary points are
almost global minimizer's matrix
completion rank a approximation so
basically everything here looks like
some modification of SVD
sort or tensor decomposition so anything
that looks like computing an SVD or
orthogonal tensor decomposition the
second order stationary points are going
to be global minimizer's okay so what
does this mean for neural networks I
know three examples where neural
networks are second-order stationary
points and I'll talk about these next
mark cities every hardware so you
talking assist the like you can only get
excellence but it's that if I do the
Goldmans Williamson relaxation is an SDP
right and then to save memory I instead
of solving SDP I make it low rank that
problem has the second-order stationary
points our global mins of VAS TP so you
almost you get the same approximation
ratio as the STP
okay okay let's talk about what is known
for neural nets well one obvious idea is
that if I have neural nets and
activations quadratic is basically
matrix sensing okay so if micro model
looks like sorry if my my model looks
like this my data can be anything my
model looks like this and I minimize
square loss or logistic loss and the
number of neurons is bigger than square
root n then all the second-order
stationery points are global minimizer's
this is essentially the same reason that
the per Montero relaxations work when
you have square root and rank well it's
kind of the same problem it's there's
some late and sdp structure here okay
with brought low activation so this one
is more tricky my true model now is
comes from a rally with strictly
positive output layer weights W star J
can be anything as long as the matrix is
full rank then I need X to be Gaussian
the output layer weights are positive
and K is less than D because I need it
to be for ik
there exists a loss function that's
implicitly doing tensor decomposition
like I can write it down but it would
take up five slides and that's the
population one if I wanted write down
the sample one take like a slide back to
write it so there's some complicated
function that's encoding tensor
decomposition and if you all
second-order stationary points of this
tensor decomposition loss or a
permutation of the global minimizer's
there just gave me permutations of the W
star case it's polynomial I don't know
yeah okay so um yeah this is yeah this
is tricky because it's Gaussian so
smoothed it out some that's why I'm
saying about disgusting you can do
either you can show that if you have
enough samples and non smooth it doesn't
hurt you on the training loss or you can
say I'm doing one pass SGD either one
will work yeah yeah exactly
the population loss is interesting it's
a mixture of tensor decompositions which
is a smooth thing okay oh sorry sorry
sorry I said that wrong sorry what
you're saying is if you do gradient
descent on the obvious loss function
like Square loss this tensor
decomposition loss is smooth even when
the activations relu yeah I'm sorry
okay so you can some things are second
order stationary points but if you are
not willing to use these really really a
convoluted and weird losses then it's
quite limited these it turns out with
one neuron it was the gradient was not
vanishing they have these one-point
convexity properties with to two neurons
and the way it's nearly orthogonal you
can show that every second-order
stationary point is a global minimizer
it's extraordinarily painful high school
trigonometry to do this and it it works
with two neurons and bowheads paper
shows somewhere around six or seven it
starts failing so this is clearly not
true and the experiment I showed you
showed you it's not true at all for 50
races this there's no way to make more
progress on this some and it's so
painful and also when you have one
convolutional filter non-overlapping
patches it's true okay so we've made a
little bit of progress but not much
using second-order stationary points and
all of these results are algorithmic
here so you first prove that
second-order station epsilon
second-order stationary points are good
and then you invoke SGD or perturb
gradient and it finds in polynomial time
okay so now I'm going to move on to law
and algorithmic results let me take
questions first
okay so for the non algorithmic results
we're always going to work in the
settings where the parameters is much
larger than the sample size and let me
just view everything as a nonlinear
least squares or nonlinear logistic
regression values least squares it's
more convenient and I'll use a shorthand
that Phi of theta is the prediction of
the network on sample X I so what is the
optimality conditions of non linear
least squares let me define a Jacobian
matrix with columns the gradient of F
Phi right this is just the Jacobian of f
of theta where you view f as a map from
Rp to RN it takes parameters and outputs
a prediction for every sample then
there's a Jacobian matrix which is P by
n so since P is bigger than n it's a
tall matrix and I'll call the residual
or there be just fi minus y I so it's a
vector of length n so if you just look
at the you take a gradient of this and
set it equal to zero the optimality
condition looks like this it's some tall
Jacobian matrix times the residual
equals 0 this is completely obvious but
a powerful observation is that when you
have a tall matrix generally the
minimums the nth singular value is
positive right tall matrices are full
rank column rank generically speaking if
this is a if Sigma min of J Sigma and of
J the enth one is positive times the
residual is 0 the only possibility is
that the residual is the 0 vector if the
residual is the 0 vector and this is a
global optimum this loss function is a
sum esc' is the out to norm squared of
the residuals
okay so if I can magically find a
critical point with Sigma min of J is
strictly positive then I'm optimal I'm
globally optimal why is this I run
gradient descent it gets an epsilon
approximate critical point and then I
just do one step and then the norm of
the residual is less than epsilon
divided by a signal energy as long as
this is lower bounded I'm done right I
found the training lost out to training
losses order Epsilon any questions
before I go
yes I have that in one slide yeah okay
so the only thing to do here is to
ensure your optimization algorithm finds
a full rank Jacobian it finds a first
order critical point and the Jacobian is
positive strictly positive not positive
strictly minimum singular value is
positive then it's epsilon global
optimum okay oh yeah other losses I was
talking about Square loss essentially
the same reasoning holds you just have
to define the residual in a different
form the residual is now the derivative
of the loss value and so again the
residual is less than epsilon over a
sigma min and for all the commonly used
losses the derivative upper bounds loss
because it's convex right it's convex in
the Y hat argument so if I can make the
derivative zero then the loss must be at
the global minute so this non linear
least-squares analogy does work for any
convex loss or even yeah basically any
loss okay so how to find non degenerate
critical points well the short answer is
no one really knows here's a more
nuanced answer is you can of course say
topological things like for almost all
theta the Jacobian is full rank went
over parameters right like the Jacobian
is somehow function parameters but low
rank matrices are a measure zero subsets
so as long as this function J of theta
is kind of analytic ish than almost all
critical points are global minimum and
this is what a large series of papers
are essentially kind of doing under the
covers okay so I'll talk about three
different strategies people have taken
to do this the first strategy by so Dre
and Carmen uses some sort of auxilary
randomness Omega so they modify the
problem so that J
the jacobian is a function with your
parameter theta and some auxiliary
randomness Omega so even when your theta
depends on the data so notice the
difficulty is all that the algorithm the
way algorithm returns your theta is it
looks at the data and thus you know all
of these statements about almost
everywhere don't say anything because
gradient descent is of course returning
you something in a measure zero set
critical points are measure zero so the
idea of soldiering Carmen is to
introduce to inject some extra
randomness it's not completely rigorous
it kind of suggests that SGD with this
auxilary randomness can find a global
minimum I'll kind of describe this in a
second
the second strategy is to make a lot of
assumptions and somehow pretend that
data is independent this is this paper
of Kawaguchi they list some in
assumptions that make no sense to me but
somehow it implies that this Jacobian
was independent of things and then this
third one is these purely topological or
geometric statements is just say things
like almost all critical points aren't
global minimum we're almost all
basically says you just can't find a
place where the Jacobian 0 ok so kind of
they all have the same ideas I'll kind
of describe but I what I think is the
proof idea here ok so remember we're
looking to minimize F minus y the only
thing is that F is a neural network rate
the target is very clear I just want to
have to go to Y so let's look at a place
where F 0 is not an optimal what
direction do I want to move F 0 well if
I take a gradient of this it's very
obvious that Y minus F is a first order
descent direction in the function space
if I view this as objective it's very
clear I just want to move in the F minus
y direction okay so the only catch is I
need to do this in parameter space if
I'm doing I'm optimizing in function
space this is completely trivial but how
do I find a parameter that can
mimics the functional gradient descent
or gradient boosting okay so let's look
at some F of theta zero which is f 0 for
theta 0 to mimic the descent direction
we're going to need to solve an equation
like this again it's the Jacobian matrix
equals to write the direction I want to
go in when this Jacobian is full rank
any its nth singular value of a strictly
positive I can invert the matrix and
find the direction to go in and then I'm
done I've escaped such kind of points
okay so what if the Jacobian is 0 then
you can try to look at the higher order
Taylor expansion again after some
function its first order term is
potentially zero so informally speaking
you can try to look for a second-order
descent directions you can try to solve
this thing equal to Y minus F and then
this will allow you to escape certain
second-order degeneracies and so forth
you just can keep going up in order and
this will allow you to escape
k order points if you could do this
since we don't know Y minus F one thing
to do is just compute eigen vectors
minimal eigen vectors so this is
informally what's kind of happening is
that when the Jacobian is zero it's
exactly when your problem has no
first-order escape direction okay so you
can take this argument to infinite order
and then that's basically an infinite
order stationary point is essentially a
local minimizer so if the mapping is
locally onto meaning that I take a ball
around my parameters and then I apply up
to it and I get an open set in RF so
geometrically what I want to be able to
do is I want this mapping from
parameters so this is Theta zero
I take a little ball here and then I map
it under F now I go to parameter space
sorry this is prediction space and I
still want to get a ball here or some
open set if I can get an open set then I
can escape because if I can get an open
set I have the direction F minus y here
right and then if I preserve if my set
is this open set the bad case would be
is like missing a slices like this or
something and I don't see why myself
then that's a bad local minimizer as
long as it's an open set here we're on
to then it's not going to be a bad local
min okay of course it doesn't mean you
can find the direction so that's why
it's purely topological in contrast to
the strict saddle or second order
stationary points which allow you to not
only say it's on two but you can find
such a direction okay that's nice okay
so how is this related to over
parameterization so that's let's look at
to learn networks and imagine that the
hidden layer is super super wide okay
when this second when the second when
the hidden layer is super super wide I
can always find a and W is full rank
then the Jacobian matrix will in fact be
full rank sorry let me let W 0 be random
and then the Jacobian matrix will be
full rank then I can solve an a I can
only use a to find a first order there
set Direction right so this is saying
something trivial is that if you have n
Euron's
initialize them by random and fit the
output there clearly you can escape any
you know credit any degenerate direction
and get to a global min so the only
potential issue is if this matrix Sigma
of W X is ranked the trainer this
Jacobian here is actually just Sigma of
W X so okay so then how do you get out
of such directions is that
imagine a war a local minimizer where
there is not zero you just want to make
an infinite perturbation to W to make
Sigma of W X full rank let's say Sigma
is analytic and then so almost any
perturbation will make that matrix full
rank because you know analytic functions
plus rank degenerate means that low rank
things are very unlikely measure zero if
Sigma where analytic and then you make a
perturbation to a to move in the
direction of Y minus F to escape right
so this is a second-order perturbation
in the sense you move W a little bit to
ensure that your Kobe ins full rank then
you move a a little bit to go in the
direction of F minus y or Y minus F so
roughly speaking there's no spurious
local minima papers like the first paper
I could find on this was basically this
Posten paper that says something like if
all hitting layers
sorry if there exists a hidden layer
that's very wide at least and wide then
all local minima are global roughly
speaking here it is so the theorems that
look like this say something like take a
network a feed for net that's very deep
you have one layer that's very very wide
and then all the layers after that are
shrinking and with then almost all local
minimizer's are global there's a second
form of such theorem which say that with
under the same conditions that you're
very very wide then there exist a path
and the path is non increasing meaning
you go from theta to theta star and you
don't increase the objective value the
last value at all and you can move to
theta star it doesn't mean that SGD will
find such a path or anything like that
but it does imply that every strict
local minimizer is a global minima even
was available only already being
analytic
but what can you say it remedy hey I
don't know
in fact this argument is not from these
papers they have some weird proof I
couldn't digest any and none of them
cover around the way what's working
ready no it works
it requires the function to be possible
imaging and so review is one such
function no but they don't say all local
minimizer's are global right they have
extra conditions if you want right what
says the second form basically you get
the non-increasing yeah sorry you can
get this one but I don't know if you can
get that one that's prime more correct
but I think the ideas are all kind of
similar is that you basically just
perturb the parameters and then you can
if one lives very wide you can use the
outputs imagine the very wide layers at
the very end for convenience you just
want to move all the parameters a little
bit to make sure the the Jacobian with
respect to the output layer is a full
rank matrix and then move the weights of
alquiler a little bit to get the
decrease that's kind of what this is
trying to say
yeah he explained to me I think the the
gap between notes spurious local minima
and then earlier it's just in first
order methods are actually finding
second order yeah the gap is that for
example if I had imagined this was
peddlers as I had a w1 through w-9 and
then all of the W 1 through w9 are in a
rank degenerate configuration let's say
they're all 0 then I need to move every
one of them a little bit to make sure
that jacobians are full rank and then I
move a a little bit so that's like a
10th order decrease so the amount of
decrease I'll get is w now minus WL
initial to the 10th power and those SGD
will never see they'll only see it if
it's a second order difference
okay yeah so essentially these two
flavour theorems they're quite similar
at least to me is that they kind of say
that if you have one layer that's wide
enough morally speaking you shouldn't be
trapped there and the reason they're not
quite constructive is you know if you
have this non-increasing path but it's
very flat then a gradient algorithm will
never see it yeah I'm curious maybe
you're gonna discuss this but how many
orders this stochastic gradient descent
see
oh and it's trickier than that imagine
if this activation were a lieu you would
think that's a second-order decrease but
technically it won't go through because
it's not smooth and things like that if
you try to smooth it then the decrease
is in second-order anymore because
they're not zero it'll look like a
higher-order thing so there's no way to
go around this really okay so this is
also related to so maybe in the early
90s people looked a lot what they call
greedy algorithm and which is
essentially Franco for gradient boosting
and it also has this flavor of
functional gradient descent you want to
go again in the direction of F minus y
let's look at only the two-layer case my
weak classifier will be the single
neuron and I'm going to boost it I'm
going to a functional gradient descent
so now I'm going at some linear
combination of these single neurons
which is obviously now a two layer
Network so every step what you want to
try to find is a network that kind of a
pox on your on the approximates F minus
wire right okay essentially Frank wolf
is basically gradient descent except
every step you're putting in a new
neuron a zero and then you're doing some
local search on that parameter a zero to
try to find the decrease direction so if
you could find such a decrease direction
then Frank wolf converges like someone
over K rate because it's gradient
descent on function space so when can it
make the question really is when can you
find such a neuron using an efficient
algorithm so if if the adding the neuron
makes first order progress meaning it's
positively correlated with F minus y
then gradient this and we'll see this is
strictly positive correlated with the
correct normalizations so the angle is
less than 90 or something
okay so otherwise you need to find a
direction of higher order correlation so
if for example if sick if a single
neuron can't correlate with the descent
direction F minus y then it's hot it's
hard to find the notable exceptions are
when the correlation is second-order and
again you can write down some you can
write down the correct matrix eigen
decompose and solve this this is done in
a paper by Livni Shalev Schwartz and
Shamir where they looked at quadratic
activations and they showed that when
your activations are quadratic you can
implement Frank wolf efficiently and it
finds a global minimum and if the
activation is monomial again it's some
sort of Kaif order tensor decomposition
problem to try and find to try and do
one Frank wolf stuff
okay so that kind of finishes my section
on these sort of less algorithmic II
results any questions before I go on
tenants
oh yeah so can you now go for the
example of your presented at the very
beginning you don't need to change that
just going back to the example B percent
at the very beginning the experiment the
experiments yeah can you now tell us how
the theoretical results shed light on to
explain in the phenomena I mean they're
all just suggestive like I said so all
of these results I've covered so far
say nothing quantitative about the
activation was not quadratic the only
cases I've talked about with
quantitative results are single neuron
or quadratic and in fact this is not
understand there's no result in the
literature that says if my teacher
network is K neurons with order K or K
log K or even K squared I can learn it
there's no result that says this in the
literature no you need like super smooth
you need like you know non reloj you
need like monomial low degree
activations right yeah
or those you need low degree act
poly k4 constant degree roughly or
geometrically decaying this yeah but
that result on the existence of a
decreasing path from enemy sensation to
the daily minimum yeah that's under
Israeli tolerates rather this but you
won't see it in the algorithm what it's
a higher order descent it's if you can
find so let's put it this way if you can
solve a Frank wolf stuff with basically
what that requires to do is to solve
Frank wolf you you need to find a neuron
to add relu to try and get decrease yes
solving a Frank wolf stuff with a reloj
is equivalent to constrained to find a
second-order stationary and constrained
optimization which is a hard problem
it's co positivity
you need a compute like a negative
eigenvalue subject to polyhedral
constraints basically we want to solve
like men ax greater than 0 X transpose
HX it basically requires you to solve
things similar to this so that's why I
said it everything so far is suggested
but what about the opposite direction of
starting with a over Pharma trust and
and then reducing sorry what do you mean
so that problem needs to be solved in
order to add a new to add a new era and
that would be the case when you begin
with an undercover choice for women you
want to know you mean start with over
predators the problem is you can't rule
out when they all collapse and become
degenerate like you start with
infinitely narrow many neurons and they
collapse to a lo mejor set if you can
say that they stayed absolutely
continuous and quantitatively then yes
all of these are then yes it's a goal
woman
any other questions yes
oh but great in three methods when you
or one zero-order optimizations like
will be some strategies in a I don't
know what I don't think they would I
don't think they were guaranteeing
although I don't know of any study of
them either so at least recently
yeah it's maybe trivial but in all your
formulation I didn't see by a pencil
that matters of the holder return or
it's only a trivial to adjust a call
like to put at one in action that's an
interesting question
with I'm not actually sure some of these
results are very sensitive I think some
might break with biases I think I think
a lot of them break with biases except
the topological ones I chose our
pipeline a lot of the like quadratic
activation might they might thank you
okay yeah yeah let me just say what I'll
talk about next time
all right so next time I will talk about
results at our algorithmic these local
these results that allow you to locally
linearise yet get the error to zero or
very small and then I'll talk about why
they're not quite a complete
understanding yet and contrast them
through some work on these global
dynamics this Wasserstein viewpoint and
that's all for today
[Applause]
[Music]